I was going to ask you you you mentioned
that people were felt like TMZ did the
bidding for Trump and I feel like a lot
of all the news networks are pretty much
guilty of that no they weren't I think
CNN did in terms of just how much they
covered him there was like a free
infomercial for Trump day about that's
what I'm talking about okay I didn't
know I'm not talking about um I'm not
talking about like I'm not I'm not
talking about capacity did you mean when
you said that that the stories were
favorable favorable for him okay okay
that's different like because Harvey and
Trump were friends oh I didn't know that
oh they were um well I was going to ask
you just like CU because you you you
talk politics a lot on your podcast for
people who don't know go check it out
it's dope podcast High Learning podcast
the ringer podcast Network we're going
to have Cactus te on our show pretty
soon well I was going to ask you like um
where do you see cuz I don't think
Biden's going to end up being the the
guy cuz I think he'll lose I think they
probably know that by now yeah um so get
roll that out for me well I was just
going to ask you like no no no no no no
stay on your opinion so bid's not gonna
bid's not going to run so who's going to
run I think it probably be Gavin Newsome
Gavin Newsome will run okay when are
they going to make this decision I think
they got to make it after super probably
after super Tuesday so or uh after the
primaries is what I meant to say after
the Democratic primaries so they're
going to do the primaries Joe Biden is
then going to be I think he's going to
take like a if I had to predict it I
think he's going to probably just for
like health reasons just step away which
is probably like the the the way to do
it right so with every passing day every
passing second that becomes less likely
you're right because I I don't disagree
with you my thing is is do you feel like
what happened cuz I feel like the
CNN Fox News News Cycles MSNBC during
2016 2015 all you would see is Trump
Trump trump Trump Trump trump Trump
trump because it was good for Ratings
right and I feel like something it was
also a relevant news story it was it was
but I feel like something similar is
kind of happening now but in terms of
like all of these cases that are I mean
that and he broke the law right well
allegedly obviously he's going to go
have to go to court and you know it
looks like it if you were being
objective that there's some smoke there
in some of these cases yeah right so are
all these cases to me are kind of doing
the same thing the media did from the
first go round cuz I feel like it's kind
of it like making people feel like he's
like a martyr more now than
ever who who if you had to predict who's
going to be the next president right now
I will predict I would predict Joe Biden
um here's the thing so you think Biden's
sticking sticking in it if I had to
predict you your scenario is uh is not
out of the question but I'm interested
the reason why I ask follow-ups is
because I'm interested in the
specificity of it right right okay Joe
Biden's not gonna run everybody say okay
Joe Biden's not gonna run who's gonna
run are they gonna give Michelle to do
it that'd be nice is it gonna uh so so
in your situation right in your let's
say it's Nome first Trump let's say it's
Newsome right that's a gigantic problem
for the Democrats Nome is a is a I
wouldn't say a great candidate he's a
corporate Democrat like the rest of him
he's extremely corporate Democrat he's a
corporate but he is Young charismatic
who was just hanging out with Clinton
today um
speaks incredibly well he's a Statesman
he's presentable yeah Fox News was able
to mix it up with Shan Hannity or
whoever else they have him on there yeah
held his own against Hannity held his
own against the santis well actually
eight CH the eight ate Hannity's lunch
um no murdered
Hannity but okay so if Gavin Nome is
your candidate what's the problem with
that what's the huge problem with him
being a candidate I think that the
national opinion of
California is that it's in shambles and
that he's a terrible I don't think
that's big of a deal what what do you
think is the main problem then you
jumped kamla Harris so the the the fact
that you jumped kamla haris right yeah
after making such a big deal of her
being the first woman being the first
first woman vice president yeah uh VP
you jumped KLA Harris now every single
black woman not all of them but a lot of
black women let me not speak in
absolutes that uh support Democrats more
loyally than any other group I wouldn't
say blindly now no no no but but very
very like I mean my my my grandma and my
mom are like that I'm saying is though
Democrats matter I know black women are
incredibly well educated and I think
they're making decisions uh that I don't
think it's blind support I think it's
traditional support I wouldn't call it
blind okay
um those voters are now to a degree
disenchanted now that doesn't mean that
they would vote for Donald Trump I'm not
saying that at all but what I am saying
is it would be incredibly politically
risky if you were going to go with
another candidate to alienate your most
loyal base loyal base so let's say it's
kamla Gavin kamla Gavin like kamla at
the top of the ticket Gavin as as vice
president would he do
that I would I would think so I don't he
he wants to be president dude absolutely
I think he will be one day the question
is not the question is when the question
is is it 28 does does Kamala still get
her turn does she still get her turn at
president is he uh does does she come
back in 28 then does he have to wait or
does he jump her Obama jumped a couple
of people yeah it just dep sometimes you
you you grab the world in in your hands
and you have to do that jumped Hillary
jumped Hillary right yeah um and so then
when you come back to kind of what it is
we're talking about in terms of of
Donald Trump right now there a couple
questions I would ask you
uh who's inditing Donald
Trump I mean that's the question if he
gets indicted I think that is he's been
indicted well if he gets convicted
rather right so my question is when I
say who's indicted him I'm talking about
I'm asking specific questions about the
coverage right CNN CNN isn't inditing
Trump uh uh MSNBC isn't inditing Trump
trump has been indicted in New York in
Georgia and he's been indicted by the
justice department Okay so those
entities indicting Donald Trump whether
you feel like it's politically motivated
or not they have a duty to prosecute
crimes right and if there are crimes uh
committed under their watch and they
become aware of these crimes they're not
going to take it to indictment unless
they think they can get a conviction
right that's the only purpose of doing
it so they have to prosecute criminals
so what I wouldn't want is a justice
department or a DA or any of these
people that represent you know the
carceral uh the
carceral uh conditions of America and
the carceral state that we live in which
is bad I'm not a huge fan of just
locking people up and throwing away the
key that's not the way I look at the
world but I want I wouldn't want any of
them to not indict or prosecute
specifically a wealthy white man because
they think it's bad politically I think
if you are going no one thinks about
whether or not it's bad for the hood
when you are going to indict a man for
selling drugs and he has a family or he
has a baby's mother or he has this no
one thinks about if it's bad for his
family no for sure nobody thinks about
if it's bad for anything else when they
do that I see criminal I get criminal I
put criminal in jail so and and more
often than that when we're looking at
the other side of this those guys are
being targeted they are being stopped
and fris for sure there are police in
their neighborhoods waiting to create a
criminal out of the circumstances and
the cic dfun function and failure that
has existed in America for a very long
time there are people waiting to do that
so they're almost born into this sort of
uh legal entrapment that for a lot of
them it's difficult to escape so the
question isn't whether or not it's it's
making people sympathetic to Donald
Trump whether or not to him the question
is did he [__] do it so I think
that's the question on the factual base
but I'm talk about ctually it doesn't
matter what difference does that make
though well I mean we're you so you so
you would want you would want the
justice department to say no no no
because then that would certainly
demonstrate collusion between the
justice department the administ no no no
no what I'm saying is you're saying
they're doing their job which they are
doing I think that Joe Mo's perception
of what's happening is oh it's all
happening at the same time there there's
a reason why they don't want him in so
I'm going to vote for him that's look
here's the thing I just be honest with
you maybe maybe there are people people
who who um who are more sympathetic to
American criminals right I tell you
what people have Americans have had a
long cultural relationship with
criminality right uh
mafiosos um Scarface Scarface dope
dealers all have been lion eyes and
there've been movies made about them and
all stuff I tell you what they've never
done they've never to taken one of those
guys that they knew to be a criminal um
and decided that he was going to lead
the country so what what I'm going to
say is this if we're so deep down the
rabbit hole of uh Trump's being
persecuted or something like that has
happened to that you want them to lead
the nation that's fine you can't argue
with that it's listen it's a wild it's
not wild at all I it's a wild I just
feel like we've been living in like a
Family Guy episode or a South Park
episode the last like eight years so
like if he if he's like reelected I
would not be surprised that's all I
wouldn't be surprised either look here's
the thing when when when you ask me why
I think that he'll lose or why I think
that Biden who is objectively a bad
candidate for sure like objectively a
bad candidate right I'll give you a
couple of examples why I think that
um one history tells me Trump will lose
Trump won one election MH and then he's
been consistently losing elections since
then lost in 2020 his all the midterms
the midterms people have flipped on him
they cooled yeah the people who have
like dived into the election stealing
[__] have been losing yeah all so that
there's been a referendum from America
right uh on trumpism on the whole Maga
thing the the parts of America that are
very definitively Maga are not going to
come away from it they feel represented
in scene through that so that's not
going to change but the people who are
at the margins of that that actually
flipped elections they have been going a
different way so I would have to see
them elect him again
for me to change Trend not for me to
believe it cuz they did do it in 2016 to
change Trend number one I also do think
that as the criminal uh trials begin and
as things Mount he will probably become
even less desirable by some of the other
people on his side the Republicans are
working against Donald Trump right now
they're a lot of money for trying get n
whatever not going to be able to do it
he's still going to win but I'll say
this um so with all of that stuff like I
think that Joe Biden uh probably still
would beat Donald Trump if uh if he ends
up in a general election but Joe Biden
and the
Democrats are doing themselves I'm a I'm
all the way to the left they're doing
themselves a tremendous disservice in
the way they are running their campaign
I just saw Obama like sources close to
Obama said that he's there you go yeah
so
um you saw that story about I did see
there there couple of measurables out
there that actually look good for the
president that look good for his
administration uh economy is coming back
not the way people would want it to come
back but it's coming back robustly not
maybe as quickly as people want to come
econom is cominging back gas prices
coming down um we keep talking about how
bad things are in the streets data says
got to talk to people you always have to
talk to people but data says that
violent crime is down in most of the
places where it was up before there's
still places where it's terrible and if
you're on ground in some of these places
and you talk to people they're going to
get you're going to get all kinds of
different stories about how their lives
actually are I get that so there are
things to message they're not messaging
them well they've always kind of been
the worst at uh promoting themselves
they're they're they have a messaging
problem well well one a branding problem
well one problem they have now is that
they don't have an
executive that's
capable of speaking uh with authority
and
Charisma to his wins or to hisil his his
failures they don't have that he's not
capable he's not capable and for
whatever reason they've sidelined kamla
Harris she hasn't been where she needs
to be people think that these things are
criticisms of the de of the Democrats
that I make I'm not Democrat but I said
I'm all way to the left but I don't have
any party affiliation uh people think
that these criticisms I make of the
democratic party are ones that I'm
making because there's some sort of
secret agenda from me uh or from anybody
else there observations that I hope that
people would listen to so that these
things would change